un monsieur bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
est en train de vivre une situation
inédite car deux vagues se croisent
deltae omicron quelle est la situation
actuellement à l'hôpital
bah écoute et j'écoutais le professeur
mais garbani là à peu près tout dit le
nombre de passions kovy de augmente dans
les établissements mettant à mal
immédiatement en fait les activités
programmées réglé
dans mon établissement c'est le cas
également en fait voilà en fait ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est effectivement on a des
commentaires sur l'épidémie domi au
micron plutôt rassurante c'est à dire
que a priori ce variant la emmène amène
moins deux personnes à l'hôpital entre
est moins de séjour en réanimation le
problème c'est que cela se passe en
regard d'un système de santé qui est
déjà à bout
on est là on peut pas on peut pas
accélérer à l'hôpital il y manque des
lis partout il manque des mêmes des lits
de réanimation on a déjà des programmes
est pour delta depuis début décembre
donc en fait si vous voulez c'est une
illusion c'est une illusion c'est de la
communication politique de faire croire
que ça va bien se passer quand on écoute
le ministre de la santé par exemple
alors il dit quand même que l'hôpital
bertrand tension mais faut pas se
tromper c'est pas le coc victimes et
l'hôpital en tension c'est le système de
santé défaillant c'est insuffisant sur
lequel arrive une vague virale pandémie
virale mais en fait dans un monde idéal
cette pandémie ne devrait pas avoir tant
de retentissement sur loup le gros
problème c'est que vous l'avez bien dit
dans votre reportage depuis le début de
la pandémie rien n'a été fait le secteur
de la santé n'a eu aucun effet
les soignants sont quand même parti ça
n'a absolument pas provoqué de choc
d'attractivité rien n'a été fait ça veut
dire qu'en vingt mois vous rendez compte
on aurait pu provoquer on aurait pu
former deux générations d'aide-soignante
et on aurait quasiment pu former des
infirmières qui seraient à deux ans de
formation quasiment voyez au lieu de
trois alors en ce qui concerne les
médecins c'est pas tellement un problème
de médecins actuellement le médecin si
on avait été malin on aurait pu les
répartir dans les endroits où il fallait
des médecins voyez ce que je veux dire
on aurait pu mobiliser les médecins le
gros problème c'est les ressources
paramédical et dans votre reportage il
est optimiste 1 quand vous dites en
région parisienne on couche pas la
pédiatrie à la cancérologie je peux vous
dire qu'il ya des cas à droite à gauche
hmm hmm cas de cancer sont des cadets 1
donc non c'est dramatique les ce qui est
dramatique c'est l'état sanitaire alors
on tombe bien votre discours à manque de
moyens manque de personnel le personnel
de santé les lits d'hôpitaux également
manquent à l'appel on sait que en
réanimation ce sont principalement des
patients atteints du variant delta qui
occupent donc ces lits de réanimation
mais on voit également qu'il ya une
déprogrammation de certaines opérations
qui ne sont pas urgentes entre
guillemets est ce qu'on est en train de
choisir finalement elle les personnes
que l'on voit opérer que l'on doit pas
opéré
oui oui alors quand même pour être
madame pour être tout à fait précise les
ils ne manquent pas
les lits sont là mais ils sont vides
parce que on n'a pas le personnel on
revient donc que les gens comprennent
bien quand on dit on n'a pas assez de
lui en fait les lits existe mais il nous
faut des lits armes ont elles bien armé
de personnel
alors oui on commence à faire des choix
c'est à dire qu'on arrête la chirurgie
fonctionnelle
les prothèses de hanche les prothèses de
genoux et on arrête également la
chirurgie bariatrique donc la chirurgie
de l'obésité
parce que ce sont les dans les prothèses
sur gée bariatrique ce ne sont pas des
chirurgies vital on peut les décalés
cependant vous savez il ya des gens qui
ont besoin d'une prothèse qu'on va
décaler et pour eux c'est pas très
agréable quand on a mal au genou à une
hanche qu'on peut pas marcher si vous
voulez ce qui est scandaleux c'est les
bleus les voeux du président macron et
les déclarations de verrons quand ces
gens-là ils disent qu'ils ont de
l'espoir pour 2022 alors qu'on est dans
un pic des programmes la déprogrammation
est absolument scandaleuse on ne devrait
pas dans un pays moderne de voir des
programmes et pour gérer une pandémie
virale c'est un scandale parce que ça
veut dire que on va déprogrammée pour la
grippe alors bien prendre des programmes
et polar pour la gastro entérite et puis
on va déprogrammée pour la canicule cet
été
donc en fait quand on passait par des
programmes et il faut juste faire
l'effort vers le système de vata et il
ne faut pas cet effort là merci beaucoup
en tout cas à monchy d'avoir pris le
temps de répondre à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes anesthésistes
réanimateurs du médical fondateur du
collectif santé en danger